voilà mon stop il y a comme cela des
passions que l'on découvre tandisment et
qui deviennent de véritables occupations
de l'annoncer quelque chose elle qui a
découvert les subtilités de la sculpture
sur roche voilà seulement quatre ans et
depuis elle passe ses journées à tailler
la roche et à faire naître de ses mains
de magnifiques objets qu'elle a
l'occasion de faire admirer lors des
expositions
d'une part je suis
même du côté de mon père c'était des
Malgaches du côté de ma mère c'était
un dial des codes du Bengal et bretons
donc je veux dire sûrement loin
mais moi mes grands-parents et mes
parents n'ont pas du tout mon père était
cultivateur ma mère est occupée de ses
enfants bon là voilà par contre ils ont
ils aimaient beaucoup aussi comme
beaucoup de créoles d'ailleurs qui
aiment le jardin leur plante leurs
fleurs
une nature qui a fortement influencé
l'enfance de de l'aide
j'ai toujours aimé les galets les roches
j'ai toujours amené des roches partout
chez moi même très jeune je ramenais des
galets de la ravine chez mes parents qui
se demandait pourquoi je
qu'est-ce que j'allais en faire et je
faisais des allées et puis plus tard
chez moi comme j'ai été j'ai eu mon ma
propre maison j'ai toujours amené des
galets à la maison toujours cette
attirance pour le galet mais jamais
j'aurais pensé qu'un jour je sculpterai
ça c'est c'est vrai que
c'est venu
tout d'un coup cette passion
j'ai commencé mais c'est pas fini alors
là il y a juste les bosses et puis je
vais continuer
toutes les roches de la Réunion sont
d'origine volcanique puisque la Réunion
est volcanique donc toutes les roches
sont volcaniques mais quand elles ont
plus son plus ou moins vieilles plus ou
moins érodée plus ou moins
ayant la réclaction du temps et chimique
de de l'eau et de l'érosion le galet la
roche a évolué donc c'est pourquoi elle
a des couleurs différentes mais en fait
toutes les roches sont volcaniques quand
en fait la Roche La Roche neuve
volcanique enfin la lave toute neuve
elle se travaille très très mal parce
qu'elle est très friable
mais à ce travail aussi et je j'ai déjà
fait même avec des scories et on trouve
plein de couleurs différentes des verres
des roses des bleus des tachés d'aller
tâcher de baron même je trouve certains
galets on m'a demandé dans les
expositions s'ils étaient pas alors que
c'est naturel
pour travailler je
suis à quatre pattes je suis assise par
terre je fais pas attention du tout
quand je suis dans le même
récemment on m'a dit que comme j'étais
j'étais très enrhumé et puis j'ai fait
une espèce d'alégie à la poussière et je
suis incapable de travailler avec un
masque et donc pour polir la pierre et
même et le bois aussi pire encore le
bois il faut mettre il faut se protéger
donc j'ai des problèmes un petit peu de
ce côté là parce que je fais pas trop
attention à mon corps quand je travaille
je suis
impatient qu'il en porte voilà vous
faites un dessin sur la roche non pas du
tout pas du tout je sais mon intuition
qui
me fait
qui pousse ma main à tailler la pierre
est-ce que vous pensez inspirer de la
nature qui vous entoure parce que vous
avez beaucoup de chance d'habiter à un
endroit où il fait très bon on entend
les oiseaux chanter est-ce que c'est une
sauce d'inspiration pour votre je pense
oui j'ai toujours aimé de toute façon
j'aime beaucoup le
j'allais dire à la solitude pas vraiment
mais vivre dans la nature et
ça ça remonte aussi à l'enfance parce
que j'étais quand j'étais petite
j'allais souvent avec mon père dans les
champs et au bord des ravis tu as les
ravira c'est du bois pour le refaire le
manger enfin tout ça donc
j'aime beaucoup la nature et je me suis
toujours inspirée de je pense que c'est
une chose d'inspiration à la nature
c'est beaucoup de femmes et beaucoup
beaucoup de femmes et je
sais pas je quelqu'un
c'est maternel aussi c'est un peu bon il
y a des femmes une femme avec un enfant
des femmes ensembles beaucoup de femmes
puisque je trouve que le charme c'est
féminin déjà et puis je n'arrive pas
aussi je fais des masques plutôt
masculin mais je travaille plutôt les
femmes vous vendez vos sculptures vous
les exposez assez fréquemment oui j'ai
beaucoup exposé l'année dernière et les
années précédentes depuis 96 et
bon bah je
oui je vends dans les expositions
l'année dernière j'ai fait deux
expositions à San Francisco avec
d'autres
et sculpteurs et puis
à Paris pour le salon de l'outre-mer
j'exposé
ce salon qui a lieu tous les ans à Paris
ça fait la deuxième fois que j'expose
j'ai fait des expositions à la réunion à
la maison du monde à Saint-Gilles le 7
dans un hôtel enfin voilà quoi vos
enfants qu'est-ce qu'ils en pensent à
mes enfants je crois qu'ils sont fiers
de leur de leur mère
je crois et tous les trois
ils sont ils emmènent des moments de
visites
j'ai une exposition bon bah il m'aide
ils sont vraiment
ils aiment bien ce que je fais ils sont
contents de son fier de de ce que font
leur mère n'avait pas fait que ça non je
vais pas faire que ça j'ai commencé par
bon j'ai été institutrice il y a très
longtemps ça a pas durer longtemps
d'ailleurs après j'ai travaillé j'étais
secrétaire datant danse dans un lycée
technique pendant longtemps et puis il y
avait
27 ans j'ai commencé à tisser pendant
longtemps très très longtemps jusqu'à il
y a 10 ans j'ai fait de du tissage des
vêtements tissés à la main et des
vêtements des tissus fins
ce que je porte là c'est si c'est à la
main et père et tu sais et
pourquoi avoir arrêté parce que j'avais
des c'est très dur le tissage beaucoup
plus je pense que c'est si on le fait
régulièrement et trop longtemps c'est
beaucoup ou disons aussi aussi dur
physiquement que la sculpture c'est une
une on l'appelle pierre Delbourg c'est
une formation
assez rare de travailler avec d'autres
matières que la roche un peu de bois il
y a des du cocotier en particulier j'ai
travaillé mais pas beaucoup je préfère
travailler la pierre
je peux faire ce que j'ai envie de faire
et c'est c'est
chouette quoi parce que bon
je suis quand même aidé parce que je
veux dire mon mari il est il m'a
toujours aidé dans tout mais il est pris
à chaque fois que j'ai eu une passion il
s'est impliqué et bon
souvent je suis pas très ménage je suis
pas je suis pas trop fan d'intérieur par
contre